[Musique]
dans le grand montréal
de 1990 à 2000 13 des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre ont diminué de 25%
maintenant est ce qu'il sera facile de
maintenir la cadence pour répondre à la
question il faut d'abord observer
là où les gains se sont réalisés depuis
1990 on a progressivement abandonné le
mazout dans les maisons et les commerces
et lorsqu'on remplace le mazout par
l'hydroélectricité par exemple ont
réduit de 90 % les émissions de gaz à
effet serre d'un bâtiment
ensuite si à moins de gaz à effet de
serre à montréal c'est aussi parce que
les grandes pétrolières ont fermé eudes
après l'autre les grandes raffineries
dans l'est de l'île ça c'est une bien
maigre consolation pour tous ceux qui
ont perdu leur emploi
finalement on gère mieux nos déchets
qu'à l'époque les méthodes de captation
des biogaz son meilleur qu'avant la
preuve l'ancien dépotoir de la carrière
miron non seulement l'ancien poubelles
de montréal est devenue un immense parc
mais les biogaz qui s'en échappe servent
à chauffer le bâtiment de la tohu qui
est juste à côté ça c'est les progrès
qui ont été réalisés maintenant est ce
qu'il sera facile de maintenir la
cadence pour y arriver il faudra
sérieusement réfléchir à la question du
transport le transport est responsable
de la moitié des émissions de gaz à
effet serre dans le grand montréal
depuis 1990 les émissions de gaz à effet
serre pour le transport routier ont
augmenté de 16% et depuis le parc
automobile ne cesse de grossir il ya
plus de taux plus de vitesse et plus de
camionnettes bref il faudra donc
modifier nos habitudes en matière de
mobilité pour vérifier quelque chose
voici l'adresse
[Musique]